la création originale des tortues
est née d'une passion amoureuse et d'une
soirée tardive par maladresse.
J'ai fait ce dessin d'une tortue
debout avec un masque sur des nunchakus enroulés
autour de ses bras et je l'ai mis sur un bureau
et ils ont dit que ça allait  être la
prochaine grande nouveauté des Tortues Ninja
[Musique],
la série animée est sortie en 1987,
quand j'avais cinq ans, le
film d'action en direct est sorti en 1990. J'avais
huit ans, c'était comme si parfaitement adapté
à quelqu'un de mon âge. Les Tortues Ninja sont
quelque chose  dont nous sommes tous
obsédés depuis que nous sommes enfants. Je
me souviens avoir quatre ans et je
voulais tous les jouets, les figurines, les
dessins animés, les draps. J'étais juste un
peu obsédé par eux. J'ai commencé à faire
du karaté probablement à cause de Teenage
Mutant Ninja.  Tortues, combien d'amour a été
mis dans leurs créations et leurs accessoires,
mon père m'a acheté des nunchucks à cause de l'
illustration du paquet Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles et tout était
drôle et bizarre et a raconté une histoire,
ils nous ont appelés et nous ont dit, est-ce que vous seriez
un jour intéressés  en travaillant sur
Teenage Ninja Turtles, est-ce que nous l'avons joué
cool du tout ou non non
si nous pouvons l'aborder à travers cette
lentille d'adolescent,
vraiment nous pencher sur comme une version de passage à l'âge adulte
et ils ont dit oui comme un
frère Jeff était prêt à le faire  dire que nous
devons donner à ce look et à cette sensation une sensation totalement
différente, il était comme Et si c'était
animé par des adolescents pour ainsi dire, nous avons mis
tellement de travail dans les visuels dans l'
illustration, le style est parfait pour ça,
c'est presque comme une bande dessinée underground, ça
me rappelle  beaucoup de trucs originaux
que Peter et moi avons fait
toi et tes copains c'est toi et tes
frères c'est toi et ta sœur et
ton frère je pense que beaucoup de gens peuvent
s'identifier à ce sentiment d'être un
étranger parfois
désireux de s'intégrer  être accepté, c'est l'une
des émotions les plus essentielles.
Les fans sont incroyablement géniaux, que ce soit
j'aime tellement la tortue que j'ai porté le
même costume d'Halloween pendant trois années
de suite ou que j'ai eu une enfance vraiment difficile
et les tortues m'ont aidé à m'en
sortir et  c'est à ce moment-là que vous ressentez
émotionnellement l'
envie de créer, l'envie de raconter vos
propres histoires, puis de le
réaliser, c'est un rêve et c'est arrivé.
J'adore les Tortues Ninja, c'était comme la
première chose dont j'étais fan, c'est amusant
et excitant
ici.  J'ai 61 ans et je me
lève encore et je dessine des Tortues de Comics
tous les jours
[Musique]
étrangère